mesdames et messieurs les journalistes
mes messieurs nous sommes aujourd'hui
réunis pour vous présenter les
principales conclusions et
recommandations du rapport de la mission
flash
relative à la consigne pour réemploi et
recyclage sur les emballages avant de
laisser la parole à notre rapporteur
Martin de Sidrac permettez-moi de
partager avec vous quelques éléments de
contexte en janvier dernier le
gouvernement a annoncé le lancement
d'une concertation concertation qui
porte sur la mise en place éventuelle
d'un ou plusieurs dispositifs de
consignes pour le recyclage et le
réemploi des emballages
il s'agissait d'une application attendue
de la loi Haget de 2020 toutefois au
terme du débat parlementaire et des
négociations entre le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale nous étions
arrivés à un compromis et nous avions
exigé la remise en 2023 d'un bilan par
l'ADEME avant le début de la
concertation avec les parties prenantes
et avant toute décision gouvernementale
sur la mise en place de dispositifs de
consignes
en commençant cette concertation sans
disposer des éléments d'expertise
nécessaire le gouvernement a
manifestement fait le choix d'agir dans
le désordre et si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi de mettre la charrue avant les
deux en laissant planer un doute quant à
ses intentions cette mise en cause du
calendrier contraire à l'esprit de la
loi voté en 2020 et dont on entend plus
do majables que d'autres volaient du
texte ont pris de retard depuis en
raison notamment de la crise sanitaire
dans ce contexte nous avons donc décidé
de lancer en avril dernier une mission
flash au titre de la commission
d'aménagement du territoire de
développement durable relative à la
consigne pour le réemploi et le
recyclage sur les emballages avec deux
objectifs clairs
exercer les sur la concertation engagée
une vigilance renforcée
et s'assurer que le débat engagé soit le
plus complet possible
je remercie vivement Martin de Sidrac
qui a dû travailler dans des délais
particulièrement resserrés c'est qu'il
n'a pas empêché de mener un large cycle
d'audition et de tenir des expertises
les plus récentes notamment celle de
l'ADEME dont les bilans tant attendus
ont été rendus publics il y a une
dizaine de jours sans plus tarder
mesdames messieurs journalistes je
laisse donc la parole à d'autres
rapporteur pour vous détailler le sens
de ces travaux Martin
merci président
mais mesdames et messieurs comme il y a
4 ans à l'occasion de la loi à Jacques
nos travaux ont été guidés par une
exigence fondée notre politique
d'économie circulaire sur une priorité
évidente qui est celle de
l'environnement cette exigence se
traduit de plusieurs manières
premièrement il me semble indispensable
de faire de la réduction et du réemploi
des emballages une priorité réelle
et non seulement théorique car derrière
les priorités affichées la prévention
est indéniablement le parent pauvre de
nos politiques publiques d'économies
circulaires réduire les quantités
d'emballage ne se décrète pas cette
ambition se planifie appelle une
attention politique constante et
requiert d'importants moyens
opérationnels et financier deuxièmement
il m'a semblé primordial de nous
intéresser à tous les emballages et pas
seulement au Totem que constitue la
bouteille plastique qui ne représente
somme toute qu'un centième des déchets
ménagers 2,8% des déchets d'emballage et
15,4% des déchets emballages en
plastique enfin j'estime nécessaire que
nous nous intéressions à l'ensemble des
leviers disponibles les dispositifs de
consignes étant qu'un moyen parmi
d'autres pour améliorer nos performances
en matière de prévention et de gestion
des déchets d'emballage
le rapport d'information que je vous
présente ce matin tient également compte
de l'évolution évidemment du contexte
depuis la promulgation de ce texte
premièrement le contexte sanitaire la
pandémie a retardé la mise en oeuvre de
plusieurs volets de la loi geai à
l'instar du déploiement de la repallage
de la restauration initialement
programmée en 2021 et repoussé à 203
contexte économique et social par
ailleurs la guerre en Ukraine a provoqué
une vague inflationniste inédite au
21ème siècle nous invitons à manier avec
précaution des politiques publiques qui
pourraient avoir un impact sur le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens une
chose est certaine les retards accumulés
par la France tant en matière de
prévention que de collecte et tri pour
recyclage appellent une action
déterminée
c'est le sens des 28 propositions du
rapport qui a été adoptée à l'unanimité
la semaine passée
commençons par la prévention en la
matière l'adoption d'objectif futile
législatif ne suffit plus pas plus que
l'empilement de mesure parfois
ponctuelles certes bienvenue mais inapte
à engager un changement structurel des
modes de production et de consommation
nous devons donc changer de braquer
c'est le sens de la proposition des
propositions du de 1 à 9 du rapport
d'information
au regard des derniers bilans publiés
par la dame qui confirme les nombreux
gains environnementaux permis par un
système de consignes pour réemploi
j'estime notamment que le gouvernement
doit se saisir de la faculté qui lui est
donnée par la loi de mettre en oeuvre
des dispositifs de consignes pour
réemploi sur les emballages en verre en
vue d'atteindre nos objectifs de
réduction et de réemploi nous proposons
également d'accélérer le développement
et la diffusion des standards
d'emballage réemployables ou encore de
mieux contrôler les corps organismes
pour garantir la teinte de nos objectifs
passons maintenant à la collecte pour
recyclage on la matière nous sommes
également loin du compte le retard est
particulièrement marquant pour les
emballages en aluminium et surtout en
matière plastique
ces mauvaises performances nous invitent
à sortir du statut quo tous les leviers
pertinents d'un point de vue
environnemental et économique doivent
donc être mobilisés nous avons donc
adopté de nombreuses propositions
tendant améliorer le geste de tri c'est
le sens des propositions 10 à 17
j'estime par exemple nécessaire de
lancer dans des plus brefs délais une
campagne nationale de grande ampleur
notamment pour permettre la montée en
puissance des extensions des consignes
de tri nous devons également soutenir le
développement de la tarification
incitative dont l'efficacité n'est plus
approuvée en levant les freins
financiers techniques réglementaires ou
législatif qui entravent son
développement
parallèlement à l'amélioration du geste
de tri une amélioration de la collecte
est indispensable à l'attein des
objectifs que notre pays s'est fixé
c'est le sens des propositions 18 à 26
pour financer l'adaptation des schémas
de collègues du bac jaune le principe de
responsabilité élargie du producteur qui
fait reposer les coûts différents à la
prévention et à la gestion des déchets
sur les metteurs sur le marché doit
mieux s'appliquer dans le cadre de la
repemballage je propose donc d'augmenter
le taux de couverture des coûts du
service public de gestion des déchets
dans la continuité de nos travaux sur la
loi fusion fusion des filières repes
derniers ce taux de couverture pourrait
de sur quoi constituer un excellent
levier incitant les collectivités
territoriales à développer un programme
de collecte ambitieux compatible avec
nos objectifs nationaux
un bonus incitatif tendant vers une
couverture intégrale des coûts du
service public pourrait être attribué
pour récompenser les collectivités
territoriales menons et programmant des
actions compatibles avec nos objectifs
par exemple pour celles mettant en place
une tarification incitative nous devons
aussi améliorer les performances de la
collecte sélective pour les produits
consommés hors foyer améliorer la
collecte c'est enfin l'adapter à la
réalité des territoires nous avons donc
des recommandations spécifiques au
territoire urbain touristiques et
ultramarins dont les performances sont
souvent bien inférieures à la moyenne
nationale
si on s'appuie sur le bilan de la dame
publiée la semaine passée le déploiement
de l'ensemble des leviers identifiés par
notre rapport pourrait permettre
d'atteindre l'objectif spécifique de 90%
de collecte pour recyclage des
bouteilles plastiques pour boissons à la
condition toutefois d'être intégralement
et pleinement mise en oeuvre
améliorer nos performances en matière de
collecte et de tri pour recycler
implique-t-il de mobiliser en complément
une consigne pour recyclage sur les
emballages de boissons notamment sur les
bouteilles plastiques voir sur les
canettes en aluminium question
pour notre commission cela ne fait pas
de doute à ce stade la consigne pour
recyclage ne constitue pas un levier
pertinent d'un point de vue
environnement environnemental et
économique séduisant et économique
séduisant en première abord le
dispositif est en réalité porteur de
nombreux effets pervers de plus à
l'inverse du scénario reposant sur une
consigne pour recyclage qui ne porterait
que sur un gisement spécifique bouteille
en plastique éventuellement canette en
aluminium les solutions
identifiées par notre rapport ou un
avantage majeur elle contribueront à
améliorer le recyclage de l'ensemble des
déchets d'emballage ainsi que des
papiers et cartons tout en incitant pour
certains d'entre elles au tri à la
source des billets
pourquoi s'opposer à ce jour à cette
consigne donc pour recyclage les
arguments développés dans mon rapport
étayé par les bilans de l'ADEME publié
la semaine passée sont nombreux ils
peuvent se résumer en trois grands axes
premièrement la consigne n'est pas aussi
performante qui n'y paraît notamment car
la teinte de l'objectif de 90% de
collecte pour recyclage des bouteilles
en plastique avec un dispositif de
consigne repose sur un ensemble de
conditions dont rien indique qu'elle
puisse être remplies deuxièmement la
consigne pour recyclage est une fausse
bonne idée environnementale s'inscrivant
à contre-courant de la marge de
l'histoire tendant à réduire les déchets
en particulier plastique nous estimons
que loin de lutter contre le plastique
la consigne pour recyclage en pérennise
la production et la consommation
par ailleurs la consigne complexifie le
geste de tri alors qu'il venait tout
juste d'être simplifié avec l'extension
des consignes de tri aussi les
bouteilles en plastique ne sont que la
partie visible de la pollution plastique
et des enjeux d'économie circulaire
troisième axe d'arguments la consigne
pour recyclage est un gouffre financier
qui sera supporté par les contribuables
et les consommateurs à la lecture du
bilan de la dame j'estime le surcoût des
scénarios avec consignes pour les
citoyens à un montant compris entre 181
et 229 millions d'euros par an à partir
donc de 2029 en définitif il me semble
que la consigne pour recyclage constitue
pour leur une impasse comme le permet en
l'état le projet de règlement européen
emballage une clause de revoyure
pourrait être prévue en 2026 pour
réévaluer la pertinence de mettre en
place une consigne pour recyclage sur
les emballages et juger de l'efficacité
de l'ensemble des autres leviers
ambitieux
identifiés par notre rapport
d'information je vous remercie pour
votre attention et me tiens bien sûr à
votre entière disposition pour répondre
à toutes vos questions je vous remercie
je sais pas si ça marche ah si ça marche
Emilie cosse de contexte j'ai deux
questions par rapport à ce que vous
venez d'annoncer vous parlez de bonus
incitatifs du coup pour les
collectivités donc pas de malus
pas de malus s'il y a en fait un volet
aussi sanction en fait puisque comme
cela a été dit un petit peu dans mes
propos liminaires vous avez les
propositions que je vais vous trouver
qui sont dans l'axe en réalité 2 dans
lesquels en fait nous faisons plusieurs
propositions de
pour encourager l'incitation mais aussi
éventuellement pour comment pourrais-je
dire pour pénaliser les collectivités
qui ne sont qui ne s'engageraient pas
sur l'ensemble des dispositifs proposés
à travers ces 28 mesures puisque comme
cela a été dit dans les propos
liminaires pour que nous puissions
atteindre nos objectifs sans forcément
mettre en place cette consigne pour
recyclage des bouteilles en plastique il
est fondamental que nous puissions à
mettre en oeuvre l'ensemble des mesures
proposées dans les quatre axes de du
rapport que nous que nous vous
présentons aujourd'hui et ma deuxième
question c'est vous vous parlez d'un
surcoût financier pour consignes en
citant le rapport de l'ADEME mais il me
semble que l'ADEME dit que quoi qu'il
arrive
les deux solutions les deux systèmes
coûteront peu ouprou la même chose
est-ce que vous avez évalué le coût des
propositions que vous faites du coup
sans consigne
l'évaluation puisque on voit en fait
quand je parle des 181 millions et des
229 millions en fait vous voyez c'est
une marge qui a qui est assez large en
tant que tel c'est en réalité le coût
estimé de
de la consigne en fait en tant que tel
vous voyez qui ne revient pas donc
est-ce que c'est le sens de votre
question non c'est juste qu'en fait la
dame
la dame a dit que même un système sans
consigne coûterait aussi de l'argent et
je voulais juste savoir ce que quelle
était votre réaction par rapport à ça
c'est
peu ouprou la même chose en réalité non
en réalité nous ce que nous estimons à
travers les études et les auditions qui
ont été menées menées au niveau de notre
commission c'est que en fait le
fait de mettre une consigne pour
recyclage n'apporte aucun bénéfice
financier pour personne n'apporte aucun
bénéfice environnemental pour personne
et n'apporte aucun bénéfice économique
pour aucune des parties prenantes donc
c'est donc les 10 millions qui dont on
parle
dont on parle dans dans le rapport Adam
ne tient compte des consignes non
retournées en réalité et donc à partir
de là pour nous il nous semble pas
justifier de
mettre en place et de consigne pour
recyclage et s'agissant de l'ensemble
des mesures que nous mettons en place et
sont toutes un volet
vu par un prisme positif et incitatif
c'est-à-dire que l'idée c'est de mettre
en place
la majorité des propositions qui sont
faites dans ce rapport nous en avons 28
enfin et de pouvoir pousser l'ensemble
de nos collectivités et des communes de
d'aller dans ce sens-là sans forcément
mettre en place une consigne de
recyclage pour bouteilles en plastique
et sans pour autant qu'il y ait de malus
pour ceux qui iraient et qui mettrait en
place l'ensemble en réalité de ces
mesures que nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui
les annonces de Bérengère Couillard du
coup qui a évoqué tarification
incitative
enfin qui qui bonus malus pour les
collectivités locales consignes pour du
vert donc pour réemploi donc est-ce
qu'elle va dans votre sens finalement
alors écoutez elle ira est dans notre
sens il y a un moment donné le
gouvernement tranché très clairement sur
sa position vis-à-vis de cette consigne
pour recyclage des bouteilles en
plastique parce que aujourd'hui la
difficulté que nous avons et que nous
avons eu depuis le début et depuis le
début du lancement de la concertation
donc fin janvier c'est que nous ne
savons pas en tout cas moi je n'ai pas
été capable de comprendre précisément
quelle était la position du gouvernement
à cet état là vous avez suivi comme nous
donc toutes ces réunions de concertation
certaines ont été parfois reportées
parfois même simplement annulée tout ça
pour nous dire que à l'automne on aura
définitivement une réponse enfin les
conclusions de cette concertation là
moi même j'avais interpellé le ministre
je suis à l'occasion d'une question
d'actualité au Gouvernement sur les
intentions du Gouvernement par rapport
donc aux objectifs visés par cette
concertation et à ce moment-là on
n'avait pas encore le rapport de l'ADEME
puisque je tiens à rappeler que le
rapport de l'ADEME nous l'avons vu que
très récemment en fait
c'est la raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle
moi-même j'ai prévenu que les
conclusions de notre rapport ne seraient
rendus que maintenant alors
qu'initialement il était prévu que nous
les rendions il y a une quinzaine de
jours
et donc la décision du gouvernement
pourrait être reportée après les
élections sénatoriales c'est on vous l'a
dit je ne fais pas partie du
gouvernement je ne sais pas mais a
priori c'est ce qui semblerait être le
choix fait par le gouvernement oui je
crois puisque lorsque j'ai interrogé
différentes
parties prenantes de ces concertations
tout m'ont dit que au moment où nous
échangeons a priori on ne connaît pas
véritablement de date enfin on n'a pas
de date de nouvelle réunion
pour peut-être donner des conclusions ou
annoncer d'autres réunions car je ne
peux pas vous répondre à là-dessus on a
quand même l'impression que quatre ans
après on prend les mêmes et on
recommence quoi qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui a changé dans le débat par rapport à
2019-2020 alors ce qui a beaucoup changé
dans le débat entre 2019 et maintenant
d'une part je tiens à rappeler que
2023 était une ce qui était prévu dans
le cadre de la loi Jacques il était
question que l'on se reparle mais que
l'on se reparle je vais le dire un peu
différemment que ce qui a été initié
depuis le début de l'année puisque cela
a été très clair dans la loi AGEC bilan
de la dame on laisse les entre 2000 au
moment où la loi a été promulguée
février 2020 et maintenant la
possibilité aux collectivités de
déployer ce qu'elles peuvent déployer ce
qu'elles ont envie de déployer en toute
liberté on
l'ADEME fait un bilan pour voir quelles
sont les trajectoires bonne mauvaise
qu'importe et on se on se concertait on
se reparlé ont décidé collectivement de
ce qui allait être fait alors quand je
dis collectivement évidemment cela
incombait essentiellement au
gouvernement
la méthode qui a été appliquée depuis le
début de l'année une correspond pas
exactement même si les intentions du
Gouvernement annoncées étaient celles de
la loi AGEC on voit bien que d'un point
de vue calendrier chronologie c'est pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé donc à
partir de là
pour moi il ne s'agissait pas de rouvrir
comme vous le dites madame le débat de
nouveau sur la consigne des bouteilles
en plastique enfin le recyclage des
bouteilles en plastique mais de pouvoir
s'inscrire dans la continuité de ce
texte et de pouvoir se réinterroger
toutefois je vous rappelle quelque chose
qui semble avoir été oublié par par le
ministère
loi promulguée février 2020
pandémie mars 2020
et on n'a jamais vu autant de plastique
que pendant cette période là et
heureusement qu'on est qu'il y avait du
plastique aussi parce que
il n'y a pas de raison non plus
de ne voir que le verre à moitié vide
donc là dessus il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
dans mon esprit en revanche ce qui est
vrai c'est que rappelez-vous aussi je ne
sais pas quels sont vos communes et où
vous viviez les uns et les autres mais
vos élus locaux et les collectivités les
communautés sur le pont et au premier
plan pendant cette période là donc tout
ce qui concerne la loi g n'était pas
tout à fait à l'ordre du jour à ce
moment là et de ce fait beaucoup de nos
territoires de bonne foi parce qu'elles
étaient totalement mobilisées sur
d'autres sujets autour de la pandémie
non pas
initié tout de suite un certain nombre
d'actions quels sont en train de mettre
en place ou qu'elles ont démarré un
petit peu plus tardivement et nous avons
un autre acteur dans nos territoires qui
devez prendre si vous voulez cette
période des trois ans votés dans la loi
pour accompagner nos collectivités vers
ces trajectoires positives alors ils
sont 2030 que sont les écho-organismes
et donc là aussi nous évoquons un
certain nombre de points autour de cela
c'est que c'est accompagnement là à
manquer dans certains de nos territoires
et je pense que là il serait raisonnable
en réalité de se dire très bien
l'échéance 2030 nous l'avons tous devant
il s'agit pas de revenir là-dessus les
objectifs nous les partageons il ne
s'agit pas de revenir là-dessus
toutefois est-ce que véritablement quand
on sait que la bouteille pour recyclage
c'est un centième en réalité des déchets
ménagers est-ce véritablement là-dessus
qui faille focaliser toutes nos énergies
alors que l'ensemble des emballages
potentiellement mériteraient qu'on s'y
intéresse et fortement c'est la raison
aussi pour laquelle nous rappelons les
axes qu'on avait déjà rappelé à
l'occasion de la loi j'ai que sont ceux
qui concernent essentiellement l'oreille
emploi je ne sais pas si j'ai répondu à
votre question mais je crois qu'il est
important aussi de recontextualiser les
débats qu'on a pu avoir en 2019 et ce
qu'est le débat aujourd'hui en 2023 donc
voilà évidemment ça nous renvoie des
choses que l'on a pu vivre par le passé
à l'occasion de la loiget mais je crois
que le contexte est un petit peu
différent aujourd'hui j'ai aucune
collectivité moi je n'en connais pas
dans les territoires qui ne souhaitent
pas atteindre les objectifs en revanche
ce que nous disons et ce qui apparaît
dans notre rapport c'est que
c'est que il faut absolument que nous
puissions mettre en œuvre
le maximum de ces mesures qui sont
proposées aujourd'hui
j'ai encore une question
on est pas très nombreux
hier donc il y a eu des annonces sur les
ZF qui était un de ces sujets clivant
justement entre voilà entre une décision
prise à Paris et le terrain
avec un arbitrage qui s'est concentré
sur civils je crois qui les mettront en
place et puis les enfin les autres
villes n'étant pas concernés sur la
consigne pour recyclage on est un peu
dans un cas de figure où il y a une
spécificité aussi de certains
territoires où il y a beaucoup de
tourisme et donc peut-être beaucoup des
taux de collecte et de recyclage
inférieur pour les bouteilles plastiques
est-ce que vous pourriez est-ce qu'un
compromis pourrait être imaginable
autour d'un de poids de mesure selon les
territoires quoi une consigne pour
recyclage dans les grandes métropoles
qui où il y a des
des gares et tout ça et puis pas de
consignes pour recyclage pour les
commune ne plus petites alors là dessus
c'était un des questions qu'on avait eu
en interne c'était posé cette question
là mais en réalité on voit très
rapidement le la difficulté de cet
exercice là de comment pourrais-je dire
de créer des spécificités territoriales
autour de ce sujet là donc le choix qui
a été fait évidemment n'est pas celui-là
pour des raisons bon que l'on pourrait
développer mais qui que vous vous
pourrez aussi je pense découvrir lorsque
vous lirez nos conclusions donc
aujourd'hui le choix qui a été fait
c'est que on ne peut pas dissocier on ne
peut pas véritablement
dire que je prends au hasard le doux
monsieur le Président que dans le Doubs
parce que il y aurait une volonté ou pas
de mettre les consignes on mettrait un
dispositif qui ne serait pas le même que
dans les Yvelines par exemple mon
département ça ça ne nous permettra pas
d'être d'optimiser les objectifs
partagés puisque les objectifs sont
nationaux et les enjeux sont nationaux
donc à partir de là nous n'avons nous
nous pensons pas que ce soit une bonne
solution et nous n'avons pas fait ce
choix là du tout le sujet de des et des
feux est un sujet indifférent
effectivement dans le
qui au niveau de notre commission nous a
aussi beaucoup
occupé dans le cadre de la loi climat et
résilience mais on ne peut pas pour la
consigne des bouteilles pour la
considérés imaginez des dispositifs
territoriaux en tant que tel
on n'a pas fait ce choix là en revanche
on est ce que l'on a
identifié c'est que vous avez des
spécificités je pense notamment à nos
outre-mer où vous avez de vraies
difficultés aussi de déployer des unités
quelles que soient ces unités de
recyclage de traitement etc de nos
déchets et donc là dessus on fait des
propositions très spécifiques et
d'ailleurs je vous renvoie mais je pense
que vous le connaissez il me semble que
il y a déjà eu des échanges avec mes
collègues Viviane Mallet et Gisèle
jourdat qui ont fait un rapport sur les
déchets dans les outre-mer où vous avez
un certain nombre de propositions très
clairement édités pour ce territoire là
qui répondent justement aux
interrogations
d'insularité et d'insularité je dirais
et de rupan de région ultra
périphériques de l'Europe avec tout ce
que cela représente comme difficulté
spécificitées pour ces territoires là et
moi j'ai tendance à le dire parfois un
peu sous forme de boutade mais c'est
parce que je le crois vraiment
si je reprends l'exemple de l'insularité
donc de nos outre-mer si nous arrivons à
résoudre véritablement tous les sujets
d'économie circulaire sur l'île de la
Réunion au hasard
on saura le faire partout dans en France
en fait y compris dans l'Hexagone donc
je pense que c'est il ne faut pas nous
priver aussi de tester des dispositifs
dans nos autres mères qui ne sont pas
forcément alors qui ne sont pas
étendables de manière simple aujourd'hui
de sur le territoire national dans son
ensemble
alors j'ai deux questions en visio donc
la jeunesse peut pas prendre la parole
mais donc il s'agit de Françoise
albazini pour emballage dyest la
première question comme vous l'avez dit
la taxation incitative apporte de bons
résultats comment comptez-vous faire
pour que cette mesure soit la règle
générale
alors ben écoutez je pense que nos
collectivités territoriales
savent en fait connaissent le dispositif
de la collecte incitative cela suppose
de l'investissement au départ il ne faut
pas absolument
se voiler la face de ce point de vue
puisque ça suppose une organisation pour
notre collecte et pour nos poubelles qui
soient spécifiques à cette à cette à
cette tarification incitative donc ça il
y a des territoires qui ont déjà fait ce
choix là qui arrive et qui obtient des
résultats tout à fait performants et qui
mériteraient justement d'être des
territoires d'inspiration pour d'autres
donc par rapport à ce sujet de de la
tarification incitative nous avons
suffisamment d'exemples dans nos
territoires dans notre territoire
national pour
pouvoir voir une réponse à un ensemble
de questions qui pourraient se poser
sachant que nous allons avoir malgré
tout par moments des difficultés qui
peuvent être liées à la typologie de
l'habitat puisque nous avons à la fois
dans nos territoires de l'habitat
vertical pardon je vous regarde vous
mais parce que comme je comme la
personne est en ligne à la fois de
l'habitat vertical mais aussi de
l'habitat horizontal en fait donc
les vecteurs ne sont pas exactement les
mêmes et dans nos propositions nous nous
interdisons pas là pour le coup à
imaginer des différenciations selon les
typologies et donc pas d'un point de vue
territorial madame donc ça peut faire
écho à votre question mais qui n'est pas
le même sujet du tout on peut avoir une
différenciation donc selon le type le
caractère de l'habitat que l'on aurait
dans nos territoires
et la deuxième question
que pouvez-vous faire pour lutter contre
l'incivilité que l'on constate tous les
jours malgré les poubelles voire les
grands conteneurs installés notamment
dans l'espace public
alors
je ne sais pas si j'ai bien compris la
question incivilité des personnes qui ne
les utilisent pas vous voulez dire qui
ne mettent pas oui je pense que c'est le
sens de la question oui alors s'agissant
des incivilités je suis désolé parce que
je ne vais pas avoir une réponse
spécifique économique circulaire en
revanche l'une de nos mesures
comme qui fait partie des 28 consiste à
nous améliorer sur la collecte dans
l'espace or foyer et le hors foyer c'est
l'espace public entre autres et donc il
est évident que là nous devons pouvoir
déployer un maillage qui mériterait
d'être par exemple
identifié c'est le sens en fait de nos
propositions en fonction du nombre
d'habitants par exemple dans une commune
de temps il faudrait envisager une
poubelle au foyer
partant d'habitants etc donc c'est
spécificités je pense améliorer très
clairement d'une part
les incivilités mais moi le terme
d'incivilité renvoie à un comportement
que qui n'est pas lié à la présence ou
pas de la poubelle je sais pas si je
suis claire dans mes propos donc
l'incivilité est un vaste sujet on aura
largement l'occasion dans débattre mais
sur l'aspect comment pourrais-je dire
purement technique et pragmatique nous
proposons que la collecte or foyer soit
améliorée en déployant justement des
poubelles par exemple en fonction de la
densité de nos communes
j'espère avoir répondu à votre
oui bonjour Philippe collet pour actu
environnement je vois dans vos
propositions que vous envisagez enfin
vous suggérez de sanctionner en faisant
du tri une obligation dans la
méconnaissance et susceptible d'être
sanctionné donc on parle de sanction
administratives si j'ai bien compris
est-ce que vous pouvez m'en dire plus
s'il vous plaît enfin nous en dire plus
pardon alors oui parce que à la fois il
y a
d'informations et de prévention fort
vous l'avez bien compris puisque je
pense que là dessus nous n'avons pas été
jusque là suffisamment allant si je peux
le dire comme ça et dès lors que cette
prévention que cette information que
cette comment pourrais-je dire cette
incitation d'une certaine manière à à
mieux trier à mieux collecter enfin bon
bref tout ce que cela tout ce que cela
suppose la contrepartie évidemment c'est
que on est informé on est au courant de
ce qu'il faut faire et ça dès lors que
on ne l'a pas fait il est difficile en
réalité aujourd'hui de sanctionner
quiconque parce que quand vous allez à
Lille ou à Marseille vous n'avez
peut-être pas exactement les mêmes
configurations donc il est important
d'abord de passer par le volet
prévention et là-dessus je me permets
d'insister parce que je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui est enfin c'est une
action qui de mon point de vue doit
véritablement prendre le pas de manière
très clair très affirmé très très
amplifiée pour ensuite évidemment dès
lors que vous avez l'information que
vous êtes au courant on ne peut qu'on ne
puisse pas vous rétorquer non je ne
savais pas comment faire non je ne
savais pas qu'il fallait le faire donc
c'est pour moi ça va ensemble c'est à
dire que c'est la raison pour laquelle
là encore pardon si je me répète mais il
est important de lire toutes ces
propositions dans leur entièreté c'est à
dire que on sait pas vous voyez c'est
pas un tire oblige c'est à dire celle-ci
me plaît bien l'autre ne plaît pas
beaucoup c'est la nécessaire celle-ci
non pour que ça marche il faut qu'on
soit conscient qu'il faut quand même les
déployer toutes après avec des
intensités spécifiques à nos différents
territoires mais il faut que nous soyons
conscient qu'il faut quand même qu'on y
aille tous ensemble avec tous ces
propositions pour y arriver
de façon un peu plus concrète ça
pourrait prendre quelle forme ces
sanctions je sais que c'est un sujet qui
est soutenu par certains représentants
des collectivités oui alors Asmo à cette
étape là on n'a pas spécifiquement
tranché en fait en tant que tel mais
c'est quelque chose sur lequel il est là
nous sommes dans on n'est pas dans un
rapport législatif nous sommes dans un
rapport d'information donc
le fait est qu'il va il est nécessaire
pour nous de pouvoir le
comment dire j'allais dire amorcé de jeu
de mots amorcé le sujet
et je pense que là dessus il va falloir
faire confiance à nos élus à nos
territoires pour pouvoir trouver la
bonne j'ai pas le terme de sanction mais
la bonne le bon dispositif qui
permettrait d'envoyer le message
pour que nous n'ayons pas l'appliqué je
sais pas si je suis claire dans mon
propos c'est à dire que dès lors que
vous êtes vous savez ce qui vous devez
faire dès lors que vous avez cette épée
de Damoclès de
de la sanction toute votre tête
peut-être que nous n'aurons pas à mettre
en place de sanctions en tant que tel
donc voilà tout cela est encore bien
évidemment à
arroder et à mettre en œuvre
de ma fraise pour Public Sénat vous
venez de le redire un peu il faut
prendre les 28 mesures dans l'ensemble
pour atteindre nos objectifs ça veut
dire que vous êtes fermé au débat qu'on
puisse prendre par grappe vos
propositions alors là encore on est
fermé à rien on vous fait nos
propositions là encore je on est dans un
rapport d'information avec donc des
auditions qui ont été menées des
échanges qui ont été menés des des
propositions qui ont été faites et on
dit simplement dans nos conclusions si
on souhaite arriver aux objectifs 2030
horizon 2030
90%, il nous faut passer par toutes ces
étapes enfin ils font nous il faut
mettre en oeuvre toutes ces mesures là
et si on ne l'aimait pas toutes en
oeuvre
chacun avec sa méthode chacun avec les
spécifices des territoriales on va pas
atteindre ces objectifs mais si on
atteint pas ces objectifs que qu'est-ce
que je dis dans les propositions dans
les dernières propositions que avant
avant de conclure c'est
voyons justement dès lors qu'on les met
tout de suite voyons ce que ce que ça
peut amorcer selon les choix qui seront
faits dans les territoires et regardons
les résultats obtenus et on voit bien
que en réalité là où cela a déjà
certaines de ces mesures voire toutes
ont déjà commencé à se mettre en place
on est dans des trajectoires beaucoup
plus positives que celles que nous avons
nationale
donc on impose rien je sais pas si
c'était le sens de votre question l'idée
c'est simplement de bien faire
comprendre que il n'y a pas de solution
miracle il y a des solutions et des
mesures qui vont nous permettre
d'atteindre ces objectifs et puis j'ai
envie de rajouter quelque chose
également c'est que c'est vrai qu'on se
focalise sur ce 90% mais si on est à 89
on fait quoi
est-ce qu'on va considérer qu'on a raté
notre objectif je ne crois pas je ne
crois pas je pense que ce qu'il faut
véritablement juger c'est la trajectoire
et la volonté et les capacités de nos
territoires ça nous a pas échappé que
nous traversons des périodes un petit
peu de turbulences
mais il faut laisser la capacité au
territoire véritablement
d'enclencher une dynamique qui aille
vers cet objectif à horizon 2030 des 90%
mais si horizon 2030 on est à 89 moi je
serai le premier avocat des territoires
pour dire mais on y est enfin vous voyez
on va pas on va pas gérer un problème si
prégnant pour nos territoires nos
concitoyens l'environnement j'insiste là
dessus sur l'environnement uniquement
sur un
sur un facteur de pourcentage qu'il
faille atteindre queue de coco a
tellement mal je vais pas vous faire la
blague de Coluche que se passe-t-il dans
votre frigo quand la date de péremption
de votre yaourt est passé c'est pas
parce qu'on va avoir un léger il nous
manquera un point pour y arriver que
pour autant
l'objectif environnemental va
s'effondrer absolument pas c'est enfin
je pense qu'il faut savoir raison garder
en la matière donc moi ce que je
souhaite simplement c'est que l'on
rentre dans une dynamique forte qui est
déjà initié qui existe déjà dans
beaucoup de nos territoires et que l'on
puisse
et que l'on puisse justement montrer
qu'on peut y arriver sans forcément sans
forcément déployer une consigne des
bouteilles des bouteilles plastiques
vous avez dit plusieurs fois qu'il y
avait un
manque de prévention est-ce que la loi
AGEC visait à renforcer cette prévention
et qu'est-ce qui explique aujourd'hui
encore on soit dans cette problématique
de prévention insuffisante
alors
oui bien sûr alors on en avait parlé à
l'occasion de la loi Jacques je pense
que certains d'entre vous avez suivi les
débats à l'époque
et puisqu'il y avait je vais essayer
d'être synthétique parce que on va pas
on va pas refaire la loiget et c'était
un rôle qui était dévolu aussi aux
éco-organismes en fait qui devaient
accompagner dans nos territoires
l'ensemble des acteurs sur ces sujets là
bon je vais pas vous refaire le coup de
la pandémie c'est une réalité tout le
monde a fait comme il a pu à cette
période là mais malgré tout et ça moi je
l'ai ressenti à la fois à l'occasion des
auditions mais aussi lorsque je vais à
la rencontre des élus de mon territoire
mais je pense président que ça doit être
un petit peu pareil chez toi
en fait beaucoup de collectivités
disaient mais on n'a pas eu
l'accompagnement qu'on souhaitait avoir
et une partie de la compagnon c'est
aussi la prévention et ça ça nous a
manqué effectivement ça nous a manqué
c'est un petit peu la raison pas
seulement mais aussi la raison pour
laquelle j'ai souhaité insister sur ce
volet là dans le cadre donc de cette
mission Flash
financ
Ier alors nous sommes nous sommes
aujourd'hui en France en fait avec
pardon avec des éco-organismes qui ne
sont pas opérationnels en fait qui sont
essentiellement financiers donc que vous
avez la réponse
je ne sais pas s'il y a d'autres
questions si le président
en tout cas
en tout cas je vous remercie de
l'intérêt que vous portez à cette
mission d'information qui est un qui
pour nous était importantes ont souhaité
nous rester sur
comme je l'ai dit dès le début sur sous
cette forme un petit peu de pression
courtoise vis-à-vis du gouvernement
parce que quand on est sénateur et quand
on est la commission aménagement du
territoire et développement durable on
ne peut pas on ne peut pas ne pas être
sensible à ce que ressentent aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de nos territoires sur
ces sujets qu'il est qui les impactent
qui les impactent beaucoup et
pour tout vous dire on n'avait pas prévu
initialement président de faire cette
mission flash mais c'est lorsqu'on s'est
interrogé sur la le démarrage de cette
concertation qui nous semblait un petit
peu rapide qui est arrivé un peu
rapidement qu'on s'était dit nous il
faut qu'on aussi qu'on dans ce cas là
qu'on fasse notre propre travail pour
nous assurer que tout a bien été fait
que on a les réponses à certains noms de
questions et puis on va attendre le
bilan de la dame c'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga mais ça nous donne de bonnes
pistes de réflexion quand même par
rapport à cela et c'est comme ça et
c'est comme ça et que que la Commission
aménagement du territoire est
développement durable président
a décidé de d'initier cette mission
flash qui aujourd'hui vous livre ces
réflexions ces résultats
qui qui de mon point de vue et que nous
partageons puisque notre rapport a été
voté à l'unanimité lorsqu'il a été
présenté en commission en tout cas les
28 propositions maintenant il faut que
chacun puisse l'approprier dans son
territoire que nous puissions
aussi le partager le plus amplement le
plus largement et le plus amplement sur
un certain nombre de sujets que ce soit
comme
environnement posé la question sur des
sanctions éventuelles etc mais ça il
faudra que chacun trouve Bruxelles a
trouvé sa solution à nous de trouver la
nôtre par exemple pourquoi pas oui oui
pourquoi pas enfin tout ça pour vous
dire simplement que nous on n'est pas là
pour dire précisément
prenez cette mesure là on compte
appliquer là et faites-la comme ça nous
sommes en train de dire simplement pour
y arriver nous pouvons y arriver premier
message
il faut que les mesures soient toutes
mobilisées dans les territoires soyez en
conscients et en plus si vous êtes
vertueux ben vous serez gagnant
voilà donc c'est c'est un message simple
c'est un message compréhensible et c'est
un message aussi qui je pense peut-être
approprié par l'ensemble des parties
prenantes concernées et nous espérons
aussi que notre rapport d'information
président sera lui avec attention et
intérêt par par le ministère de la
transition écologique
aussi par Bérengère Couillard ou par
Christophe Béchu les deux les deux on
espère bien que les deux pourront nous
donner déjà leur avis et nous dire quels
sont les propositions qu'ils retiennent
avec le bémol c'est que il faudrait
qu'elle soit toute retenue si on veut y
arriver et je pense que vraiment il faut
que que vous ayez enfin vous le savez
vous êtes tous sur ces sujets là depuis
très longtemps
il faut avoir en tête que malgré tout la
bouteille en plastique la fameuse pet
dans tout le monde parle quand on
regarde le volume des déchets que l'on
produit aujourd'hui
somme toute n'est qu'un combat de
gisement quand même ne perdons pas cela
de vue ce n'est pas ça qui va résoudre à
la fois le problème de l'économie
circulaire qui est beaucoup plus vaste
heureusement ni la seule solution
environnementale en lien avec le
plastique parce que une fois qu'on aura
résolu le sujet des pet
le reste des plastiques on les oublie on
ne s'en occupe plus on considère que
qu'on a plus de problèmes qu'on a résolu
le problème je ne crois pas je crois que
ça c'est quelque chose qu'il faut quand
même que que nous ayons en tête donc je
dirais soyons dans le bon équilibre et
nous à la commission aménagement du
territoire et développement durable on
n'aura pas un autre discours que
celui-là on n'aura pas un autre discours
que celui-là et ça je pense que c'est
important de l'entendre
l'environnement est trop précieux
ecoutez s'il n'y a pas d'autres
questions moi je vous remercie de
l'intérêt que vous avez porté à ce
travail
je remercie aussi pardon j'aurais dû
commencer par là les administrateurs qui
nous ont accompagnés évidemment depuis
le début